so in terms of bad deals I think the I
think we're going to see a lot of them
frankly and they're probably going to
come from the private equity space you
know if you understand the model of
private equity they need to sell these
companies at some point they can't hold
on to them forever and historically the
what they call hold period has been two
three four years they'd say probably up
to seven and so some of them will be
able to hold them that long but a number
of them are going to get in trouble and
so you saw you're already seeing linens
and things file for bankruptcy
protection there's coming called
freescale which makes a microchip semi
campuses and you know a number of other
companies where people have probably
paid too much money now some of these
may fall into bankruptcy and that's
really the worst result more likely I
think you're going to see and I don't
know when you talk about bad deals deals
that just don't make that much money so
the private equity guys have taken all
their investors money and told them
we're going to return to you you know a
twenty percent annual return so when you
talk about bad deals I think you're
going to see a lot of deals or a lot of
private equity firms that are all of a
sudden only returning five or ten
percent now that may be better than the
market so you may say those are great
deals it's all relative